we have a really great discussion forum
for more than 18,000 of our viewers and
listeners on reddit at david pakman.com
slash our EDD IT this morning I was
checking out some of the posts and user
Mike flight said is social distancing
like temporary dieting it seems like the
current measures to flatten the curve
will work only as long as we all
continue to comply with them as soon as
we stop just like a weight loss diet the
curve comes back reopening schools in
September doesn't seem any different
than reopening schools in May unless the
virus goes truly extinct the outbreaks
will resume well listen you're you're
not wrong there is a question of how
long are people going to be willing to
socially distance I'll tell you I'm
going crazy on just day four and it's
because I I want to be out there I want
to be seeing people I want to be doing
all my normal stuff but we've got to
take it day by day and every day that we
can continue we are flattening the curve
more the idea is that by the time that
schools reopen you will have some
portion of the population will have been
infected and will have fought it off and
it is believed I know there's these
rumors about reinfection they don't
appear scientifically sound it is
believed that you are immune for at
least a year if not far longer if you
fight the virus off number two there
will be treatments that will work number
three the number of people who can
spread the disease will have been
drastically reduced so for example in
China when they've started to loosen
they are not seeing a resurgence there
being careful to the extent we can
believe the data so I agree the average
American is not going to be willing to
self quarantine for months and months
and months and that's a problem we it is
a race against time but early data
combined with knowing more about how
these things spreads suggests that if
people really behaved for I don't want
to say how long but it's gonna be a
little while hopefully we would not see
that relapse and and remember if this
does start to go down over the summer
there's a chance that when the flu
season comes back in the fall winter
that it's going to come back anyway and
the idea would be
to be prepared for that this is exactly
the type of stuff that that's being
looked at so I share your concern
generally but it does seem that
countries that are getting it under
control China South Korea as they start
to loosen they are not seeing the
relapse infection so far user
paid-in-full
says david should sell data mail
t-shirts I have news for you
data mail t-shirts are now for sale at
david pakman.com slash gear this started
because so this is like a very inside
nuanced thing a couple years ago i
appeared on this black conservative
jesse lee Petersons program and his big
thing is he calls liberal men beta beta
males this is a whole alpha beta male
thing that's become very popular in some
conservative circles to talk about who's
alpha who's beta and jokingly when we've
been looking at you know Bernie's path
to the nomination or virus spread or
whatever I have been joking and saying
data in the same way that Jesse Lee
Peterson says beta somebody on a stream
said David you're a data male somebody
else said you should make a t-shirt I
made a call about it design a data male
t-shirt data male t-shirts are now
available at david pakman.com slash gear
and I ordered a sample I'll probably be
wearing it next week and you can you can
check that out but in the meantime join
the discussion at david pakman.com slash
read it